bonjour louis maugée bonjour maurizio le
ton vous êtes membre de la cgt mais fait
également partie de cette terre
syndicale qui défend des intérêts des
retraités de martinique en soutien
également à ce qui se passe en france il
ya une troisième manifestation nationale
pour dire non à cette chute du pouvoir
d'achat des retraités en martinique
pourquoi ne pas être descendus dans la
rue parce que nous avons fait le choix
de transformer cette journée de
mobilisation en journée de réflexion et
de coopération alors ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire tout simplement que
l'intersyndicale a pris la décision
d'élargir son champ d'intervention et on
se trouve aujourd'hui pas seulement les
six organisations syndicales de
l'intersyndicale et des confédérations
mais également en présence
d'associations de personnes âgées parce
que l'idée voyez vous c'est que si les
organisations syndicales ont cette
faculté et cette puissance est force de
la mobilisation c'est le coeur des
métiers des organisations syndicales
par contre les associations de personnes
âgées ne sont pas toujours dans cette
dynamique donc rassemblement des forces
syndicales et des associations de
personnes âgées
c'est une dynamique que nous lançons
pour faire en sorte que justement les
retraités soient vraiment entendue
écoutée
alors ces associations qu'est ce
qu'elles sont venus vous dire qu'elle
comprenne qu'elle comprenne le combat
est peut-être vous faire remarquer deux
ou trois petites choses qui nous avait
échappé alors eu sonné bien entendu dans
la dynamique les organisations de
retraités ce sont des organisations
syndicales qui suivent la situation qui
suivent l'actualité
donc on était totalement phase lorsque
les interventions de la représentante de
la de la présidente de l'association de
la fédération des associations de
personnes âgées étaient revenus est
intervenu sur les problématiques de
santé et bien entendu nous sommes dans
l'actualité sur ces questions de santé
et il est évident que c'est une écoute
que nous sommes avons et que nous
partageons parfaitement puisque nos
organisations syndicales d'actifs sont
dans la dynamique du chum du vent du
vent pour sauver l'hôpital
donc il ya l'écoutent a été totale et il
faut signaler que au delà de la
fédération des associations de personnes
âgées
il y a également lomas il y a également
am d'or et nous avons sociation nous
avons également une hausse écrit en
particulier nous avons l'eau paris qui
est la leur la demande de la culture qui
nous rejoint sur la problématique des
petites retraites alors limogé on a noté
également que vous recherchez absolument
le soutien des parlementaires de delisle
est ce qu'ils se manifestent acs qui
vous apporte un soutien suffisant ces
parlementaires de sénateurs 4 députés
oui tout à fait nous avons effectivement
le soutien des parlementaires qui
confieront leur sensibilité quant aux
revendications parce qu'ils se rendent
compte aussi parce que ce sont des gens
qui votent pour leur accession au
pouvoir
donc ils se rendent bien compte que dans
les collectivités où il travaille avec
les maires avec les différents élus que
aujourd'hui la société était
véritablement menacée faut pas perdre de
vue qu aujourd'hui il y à 5000 euros de
quêter en martinique et dans les dix
quinze ans à venir on sera 135000 or
laisser la société laisser les retraités
dans cette situation de misère de
pauvreté
quittant s'aggraver sait faire que
demain on se voit dans une situation où
une fuite des sciences humaines et qui
pendent à la responsabilité d'assumer
tout cela n'aurait fait que rappeler uns
que les autres pour protester contre
augmentation tout prélèvement la csg
contribution sociale généralisée sur
commande et l'arrêt gel pension
revalorisation des pensions et autres
cas penser que ces parlementaires
laquelle pékin baghai auquel les fermes
bagages surtout yoka d'inoculer suivent
nous maintenant pour nous c'est un moyen
d'action
mais hook a fait bien de dix ans
quelques pas de questions qui semblent
intentions fait encore et bien justement
l'idée d'élargir la mobilisation
et puis les associations c'est pour
permettre non et donc à projeter
d'ailleurs de développer en action
dans les communes et d'appeler à des
rassemblements dans les communes et au
delà des parlementaires les localités
entre les sections d'alan kay saisi les
maires parce que les 6 s est en
difficulté il faut déborder beauty parce
que communal d'action sociale mais oui
parce qu'à trouver coyot dans les
situations parce qu'il ya des pauvretés
pas développé coyos et qui pour lesquels
le panier des réponses dont ils auraient
besoin mobilisation talent a également
sauf que le gouvernement ultra
majoritaire à l'assemblée nationale par
exemple qu'est ce qu'on dit avec les
retraités un haut niveau de vie
confortable ils doivent faire un effort
pour le bien commun
les pauvres d'aujourd'hui sont souvent
moins c'était retraités que les jeunes
les retraités font partie d'une
génération dorée c'est ce que dit le
camp en marche
oui mais le smac on le sait c'est le
candidat des riches est le candidat des
banquiers il peut pas tenir un autre
langage que cela est justement ce qui
nous intéresse c'est dans le débat
public faire comprendre aux gens faire
comprendre à la population
aujourd'hui on n'a pas d'autre choix que
de nous associer au mouvement de lutte
non associés mais de manière indéfinie
au combat que mènent les salariés de
l'hôpital de nos associés de manière
radicale et déterminée au combat que
mènent des salariés des ehpad riendeau
mobilisation aura lieu sur le carbet
donc c'est cette mobilisation qui doit
s'amplifier pour peser sur la situation
de et faire en sorte que le pouvoir
recule c'est pas la première fois on a
entendu raffarin indiquant une époque
que la rue ne s'est pas l'arbre qui
commandait eh bien on a on a bien vu
qu'il est passé à la trappe
donc le pouvoir des travailleurs est un
pouvoir qui doit se mettre en marche
on l'avait un travailleur ne lève cncs
irma vu des gens descendent dans la rue
contre la loi travail
le gouvernement fait du passage en force
ou simplement oui mais c'est un c'est un
combat qui sont construits rien ne se
fait en claquant des doigts
ce qui est sûr c'est que le combat que
mènent les cheminots c'est le chemin
qu'il faut suivre
il donne là le cap est là et même si la
loi est votée on continue à manifester
mais la loire qui ce vote peuvent sa
dette à bouger
c'est pas la première fois que ça
arrivera et c'est le combat la
détermination des personnes c'est pour
ça que nous appelons à des
rassemblements que nous appelons les
gens à soutenir le mouvement des
hospitaliers que noah plongeant à se
regrouper
à discuter dans les opérations coup de
poing avec des opérations coup de poing
acculèrent avec toute espèce de monde
nous envisagions nos désirs des lacets
bleus
la désobéissance civile des actions pour
rien n'est à exclure
nous devons prendre le passé certains
donnent une certaine tonalité depuis un
certain temps là mais oui mais c'est
évident mais toutes les formes
d'expression ce sont donc sont bonnes à
prendre
là on est la décision relève ou au
peuple aux gens ordinaires
donc non justement moi je pense que tout
cela il explique bien qu'il n'ya pas que
l'élite qui doit donner le ton mais la
population doit s'engouffrer dans des
dents les failles et permettre justement
une implosion du système et c'est
possible quel est le profil de retraité
ordinaire en 2018 en martinique alors
c'est un pauvre way ont retraité
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que la
retraite moyenne sur les chiffres de la
caisse générale de sécurité sociale la
retraite moyenne 6 600 euros
alors qui dit une otite moyenne dit il
ya des gens qui touchent 1000 euros et
puis des gens qui te rencontrer beaucoup
de personnes qui sont beaucoup plus
autour de 300 à laon b beaucoup plus il
en montrant % les personnes qui sont au
minimum vieillesse le million de billets
c'est lorsque vous n'avez pas une
retraite à taux plein eh bien on vous
accorde une allocation spécifique qui
s'appelle le minimum est bien entendu
qui eux qui remboursable sur sur votre
sur les générations
qui suivent donc il y effectivement 30 %
de personnes qui sont au minimum c'est
que ce qui est ce que parce que ces
personnes n'ont pas cotisé peut-être
n'ont pas eu la possibilité de
travailler tout au long de leur vie
il faut savoir que par exemple ceux qui
ceux qui vont dans le marronnage ceux
qui font quelques jours avec le bon
siège pour ceux qui seront télévision
voilà pour ce qu'ils font eux deux jours
de travail tout simplement
et puis le reste font du travail marron
du travail au noir ils vont le payer tôt
ou tard alors il faut pas poser le
problème de cette manière les gens ne
travaillent pas mon nom parce qu'ils ont
envie de travail au noir
c'est beaucoup plus parce que la société
est organisée comme ça il faut savoir
que pour prendre le secteur de
l'agriculture notamment bien c'était il
ya peu de temps de ça c'était une
activité journalière
c'est à dire on venait sur
l'exploitation et on demandait ce qu'ils
avaient dû travailler pour moi et le pou
les dockers pareil il ya plein de
métiers qui étaient des métiers en fait
journalier et en plus de ça ce qui est
en italie quatre enfants présents et ce
qui est plus que justement de petites
retraites c'est si d'une part cette
situation de travail précaire la
situation des des personnes aussi qu' on
dit qu'il est petit salaire on va
regarder par exemple dans le secteur des
collectivités
il ya plein de gens qui travaillent dans
les collectivités mais qui travaillent
que quelques heures
ceux qui travaillent dans les cuisines
ceux qui travaillent dans
l'accompagnement des enfants ils n'ont
pas le temps complet donc le fait de
travailler avec un temps partiel a des
répercussions après sur la retraite
puisque la retraite et contributive
c'est le fait de cotiser qui va donner
droit c'est à cela que manuel mâcon
devrait s'attaquer davantage
ah mais non il fait l inverse monsieur
minc ont maintenant à mâcon organise le
casse du siècle en ce moment en pétant
la protection sociale sur un journal net
de matières français j'ai lu que mâcon
envisage de
de de cirque estrées 747 milliards dit
il qui sont distribués dont par des
aides inutile par la sécurité sociale
etc dont il va en fait s'attaquer à ce
qui fait que aujourd'hui les gens qui
sont dépourvus les gens qui sont démunis
ont une aide qui leur permettent de
vivre il faut savoir que aujourd'hui les
personnes qui sont les halo 4
près de 40 % des allocataires vivent à
100 % des allocations familiales et 35
35 ou 30 % vivent avec 50%
l'affabulation sa maison alors beau jeu
mais ils ont leur image des creux ce
fameux président e
si comme commune exprime ses intentions
supprime les aides que que vont faire
toutes ces personnes là il est convaincu
intimement convaincu que tout cela ne
sert à retenir oui mais parce qu'il
vient d'un monde où on n'a pas besoin d
aide
ils viennent au monde de nantis de
privilégier mâcon ceylan des banquiers
donc il faut croire que dans cette
société là effectivement ya deux camps
il ya celui des possédants celui des
nantis celui des privilégiés celui des
précédents et puis celui des pauvres
alors il est temps que les pauvres se
reconnaissent dans lé encore il est
taclé pauvres dans leur camp se
réunissent s'associent coopèrent se
mettent ensemble se rassemblent et puis
se bat c'est ce combat que nous voulons
mener et c'est dans cette direction que
nous allons
merci d'avoir été ce matin avec nos
louis maugée porte parole de
l'intersyndicale qui défend les intérêts
des retraités dans l'article merci bonne
journée mais si mesures dont nous avons
évité